hello welcome to see you playing a belt
ignite okay prevent a g3 yeah that's an
interesting way of playing d50 name nope
I only plays five minutes yeah after 90
64 isn't good but g3 is ok I think here
White has chances for a slight advantage
ok so let's go here be ready for a five
yeah it's official has a somewhat
strange position down the soul part
structures quite unconventional okay
maybe he trades it nope but now I should
be able to threaten before alright so
before i'm not sure that I want to play
before now maybe have some other idea I
could go back trying to play be four
takes takes bishop d 492 to trade night
against bishop this is still desirable
here because the position will
ultimately open up
maybe it's just plain c59 could be four
yeah I think that it is a good move I
throw is threatening to take on on d4
and the favorable circumstances
tea set huh I didn't expect this move
but it's not bad problem
to teach it be very difficult this
position this one I was I was thinking
about be five anyway so I'm going to
play it now that it gains a tempo this
is that f4 was my was an idea trying to
gain even more space the only drawback
is the weakness of the sea floor pod so
Bishop is six you should probably me
maybe play but should be six no it
doesn't okay he's going forward III I
guess but okay I'm taking this
opportunity I think this is a this is an
accomplishment that I got an f5 and
prevent him from moving the bishop
directly to e6 Galu k 3 i'm going back
to see one maybe you can go rooks III as
weird as it looks looks a bit strange I
can also play this I think
if I can get rid of this rook then I'm
definitely in good shape but i'm not
sure if I can even Queen your aid is a
move maybe Bishop g5 against this okay
it tries to go to f7 at the end anyway
yeah should be five you probably just
goes age 6 I cannot play oopsie one
unfortunately as night b3 is coming now
I will not be three Queen B 2 nite c 1
queen a three it's possible and okay
hope I'm not blundering stuff Ian okay
492 check quickly play it but a good
move I guess
and now I can go look c3 which I wanted
to do with the whole time DSF six now
opening this up on the Kings side if he
goes age six now I probably can
sacrifice okay let's go have six so I'm
going to take and queen age 6 speed
sweep up have it checking h5 and have
six
Wow
threatening 95 check now it should be
very dangerous
check okay
black resign what a tough game or the
tough game yeah very complicated middle
game this is some what happens quite a
lot from those close down position so
you have all pieces on the wall and in
some cases really get very complicated
positions later so yeah probably f4 is
more precise now so that I'm quicker
here but okay this is from me okay five
okay three Bishop g5 given by the
engineer troll maybe this is better if
this particular moment he also cannot go
h6 as I'm taking and playing this maybe
this is better this this is probably too
complicated again Bishop g5 is very
strong I saw the idea I just employed it
a not later and takes and by now it is
not as dangerous anymore a computer
wants to play the amazing we should be
to just trying to snatch pawns but it's
very difficult this is what the computer
wants to play this is not something that
a human player would like to see engine
gives equal by the way with the Queenie
658 cruciform oh my god yeah okay this
is equal yeah kid this happened now I
have six try to break through Bishop eat
or seems to be okay for black still
remarkable and only now I'm winning yeah
Bishop b2 still seems to hold
amazing yeah now 95 is too big a threat
he he has to move now check T resigned
in a very tough game probably there were
many opportunities small opportunities
for both sides okay well thanks for
watching